of tea and keeping up with personal
precautions with more opportunities for
social gatherings festivals and travel
for many people
staying up to date with cov19 vaccines
improving ventilation and continuing to
wear a well-fitted mask can help reduce
the risk of infection and spread to
others
some of our work some of our covert 19
habits such as staying home if you're
symptomatic can also help prevent other
infections including monkey pots
globally
at least
1285 confirmed cases
of monkey parks
have been reported from 28 non-endemic
countries
as of june the 8th
in canada
as of june the 8th in canada as of the
17th
of june 2022
168 confirmed cases have been reported
141 from quebec
21 from ontario
four from alberta and two from british
columbia
we continue to collaborate with
provinces and territories as well as
partners such as community-based
organizations and representatives from
affected communities to monitor and
respond to the evolving monkey park
situation
including supporting provinces and
territories in the efforts to roll out
targeted vaccination campaigns
as well we are working together to raise
awareness of how the virus is
transmitted so people can take steps to
properly protect themselves their
friends and their loved ones
among cases for whom information is
available and has been reported to the
public health agency of canada all cases
are male and ages range from 20 to 69
years
our provincial and territorial
colleagues inform us that many cases
report sexual contact with other men
though some cases are still under
investigation
however the risk of exposure to monkey
pox virus is not exclusive to any group
or setting
anyone no matter their gender or sexual
orientation could get infected and
spread the virus if they come into close
contact with someone who has monkey
parks or the objects that they have used
like personal objects towels or bed
linens
with upcoming celebrations and festivals
such as pride events we want to ensure
canadians have the knowledge and tools
they need to safely take part in these
celebrations so let's use these events
as an opportunity to get the word out
and work together to stop the spread
we will be pleased to answer any
questions today
thank you
merci merge
bonjour
to us
positivity
have
19 readiness means maintaining awareness
of local disease activity and keeping up
with personal precautions
with more opportunities for social
gatherings
festivities and travel for many people
staying up to date with covet 19
vaccines
improving ventilation and continuing to
wear a well-fitted mask can help reduce
the risk of infection and spread to
others
19 habits such as staying home if you're
symptomatic
can also help prevent other infections
including monkey problems
globally
at least 1
285 confirmed cases of monkey pox have
been reported
from 28 non-endemic countries as of june
8.
in canada as of june 17 2022
168 confirmed cases have been reported
141 from quebec 21 from ontario four
from alberta and two from british
columbia
we continue to collaborate with
provinces and territories as well as
partners such as community-based
organizations
and representatives from affected
communities to monitor and respond to
the evolving monkey pox situation
including supporting provinces and
territories in their efforts
to
roll out targeted vaccination campaigns
as well we are working together to raise
awareness of how the virus is
transmitted so people can take steps to
properly protect themselves their
friends and loved ones
cases for whom information is available
and has been reported to the public
health agency of canada all cases are
male and ages range from 20 to 69 years
our provincial and territorial
colleagues inform us
that many cases report sexual contact
with other men
though some cases are still under
investigation
however the risk of exposure to monkey
pox virus is not exclusive to any group
or setting
anyone
no matter their gender or sexual
orientation could get infected and
spread the virus if they come into close
contact with someone who has monkey pox
or objects they have used like personal
objects
towels
and festivals such as pride events
we want to ensure canadians have the
knowledge and tools
they need to safely take part in these
celebrations
so let's use these events
as an opportunity
to get the word out and work together to
stop the spread
we will be pleased to answer any
questions today
thank you
so it's time for questions
it's the time for questions
everybody can have one question one
follow-up if you have not already raised
your hand please raise your hand if you
would like to ask a question uh the
first question we'll go to lauren pelly
from cbc
good morning
on the monkey box front
we're hearing from patients that they
are often stuck in isolation for quite
some time it can be
weeks even a month or so before the
lesions resolve so it's quite an
extended period of time for people to be
off work isolating at home
does the federal government have any
plans to offer any sort of housing or
financial support or wrap around
services um you know to make sure the
provinces can uh allow these people to
isolate for for quite a long time far
longer than anyone typically had to even
with covent
yes thank you for the question and and
you're right and we're still of course
um obtaining more information about
monkey parks in the current context
but
until we know more the most
precautionary thing to do is uh to
protect
uh against transmission um
is is to um you know be isolated
potentially for until all your scabs
have healed and fallen off and your skin
is beginning to
reform underneath
so that can take a considerable period
of time
and i think uh canadians have helped
each other
you know throughout this pandemic
certainly we encourage that
i think
all levels of government needs to do
what they can to support people in
isolation
because we've learned of course
throughout covert 19 that people want to
follow public health measures uh but
they need to be supported in certain
instances to do so but i i think um i
would certainly encourage all all levels
of government to think about how this
can be done and this is not the only
infectious disease
that is going to affect
our communities so i think
figuring out
what has worked
and providing the necessary support is a
really good thing to do
we're also hearing from
experts
in canada the u.s and europe a great
deal of concern over what could happen
in terms of transmission of this virus
in the summer
with so many gatherings coming up
can you talk more about the federal
plans to curb transmission
because we really haven't seen these
cases plateau it seems to just continue
spreading um and there's a lot of fears
that that will will uh
you know really spike in the in the next
month or two so
any more details you can share on that
front
yes so
we have been meeting with experts
provinces and also local health
departments because there are a number
of them that are more specifically um
impacted at this point uh including
montreal and and toronto
and uh looking at all the different ways
that we can break the chains of
transmission
so one of the key things that we're
doing
of course is increasing awareness both
in the impacted communities but also
amongst health workers
getting the information out to
through
non-governmental organizations is really
key
because they have the trust of community
they know how to communicate
amongst their networks so that has been
really tremendous we met with 29
organizations
that are very enthusiastic about
supporting
the increased awareness in the community
particularly as some of the celebrations
and
and gatherings such as pride is coming
up
and um and be able to frame the
messaging in non-stigmatizing uh ways
and um businesses private sectors have a
role so uh local health authorities have
been engaging with them to for them to
play a role in uh making sure that we
can reduce change of transmission
because we can we know how to protect
each other
from the trump spread
um the the other thing is of course um
getting more messaging out on social
media uh engaging uh dating apps
and we thank dating apps such as grinder
for example for their role and
collaborating with us on getting
messages out
and then of course
providing healthcare providers with the
tools that they need to diagnose people
and
because some of the skin lesions for
example can look like other skin lesions
and then how they can test
for the virus
all of that has to be disseminated
webinars are being done in different
places in quebec as well
and also of course the mobilization and
pre-positioning of the
vaccine
and that has been done in to the
it's been
essentially pre-positioned in
almost all jurisdictions uh in
particular in ontario quebec
the uptake of the vaccine is being quite
tremendous in quebec because they they
managed to
get the word out through community
groups and and
locally
and um so and so far that's been going
well with
i believe over 3 000 people vaccinated
ontario beginning their
campaign as well ahead of some of the
festivities
and then we have the antiviral
treatments those don't
necessarily
break change a transmission but they're
there to treat those who might be
seriously sick
or have
difficulties because of the lesions in
swallowing eating for example or pain
so i think um
you know those are the things that we're
very fortunate in canada that we can do
because we do have some other
countermeasures but working globally is
extremely important
and i i know that the who is having a
meeting next week to discuss monkey
parks
but there will be continuous
reintroductions into the future if we do
not collaborate and support
african countries for example
because they are the ones with ongoing
transmission in an endemic state so
there's lots
that that is happening and lots more
that can be done
i think in moving ahead
in terms of the cases and the
trajectories yes there are more cases
local health authorities are telling us
that the the rate of growth seemed to be
slowing
but we will have to watch that over the
next weeks
helps a fan mute myself uh next question
right is the patel toronto star
hi thanks for taking our questions uh
we've been told that the government
plans to get more rapid tests instead of
phasing them out do you have any details
on how many more will be obtained and
when and also whether they'll be able to
detect new variants
dr tammy on mute
sorry
you would think i would know better
after two years um anyways thank you for
the question no i don't have any details
i will have to get back to you on on
that one because i'm not directly
involved but i do know that for the
national
strategic emergency strategic stockpile
the idea is that there will be one so
there is a surge capacity to the
provinces
if
if that is needed
um and as to whether they work on that
of course the as the variants emerge
um
they'll have to be tested against
the
different types of rapid tests
um and they may the characteristics of
them might might be different and evolve
over time so it is something that we
have to continuously
uh monitor and test
and as we know many canadians are
testing positive on rapid tests these
days you know do you have any updates on
whether those test results are being
counted in official case counts and if
not how will you know whether we are in
another wave and whether we need to end
the suspension of restrictions like uh
vaccine mandates
yes so um there's i don't think we're
capturing all the rapid tests that's i
think pretty clear to me and many people
are doing that themselves or in other
settings
there are some jurisdictions trying to
capture some of that but off the tests
that we are doing we can monitor trends
and including wastewater signals as well
which is why you know i in my update
today i'm saying that you know we've had
a number of weeks of decline
in
a number of indicators
but there are some ups and downs
and so including in the wastewater
signals so some areas of canada might be
beginning to see a bit of a rise that
could be due to multiple reasons
including increase in contacts but also
we're watching those variants um as well
so we are able to through our current
surveillance systems which is not about
testing every case but enough that the
trends can be observed and i think we
are able to still do that
in a combination of of ways using the
different systems
and it is important to do pcr because we
need to get the virus samples in order
to sequence them and see what kind of
variants
we're getting
some variants of course escape
certain screening tests and and we have
to monitor that
over time as well
but i do think that the virus is very
much circulating around the world
and so we might see some bumps even in
the summer
but we have to prepare for the fall
where there's there's going to likely be
more activity
there
is an increase in 19 cases
for ba four and ba five we've seen an
increase yes
over the last few weeks
especially the
ba four and bfr do have an advantage
they have an immune escape with respect
to other variants
so this is something that we need to
follow
also
we have
possibly some
uh indication that there is that they do
have immune escape for the ba four and b
a5 variants
seen
[Music]
scientific data so far that you still
have a good protection against severe
illness with the vaccination so it's
very important
to now get your booster doses
because
[Music]
this is for the protection of the
population
uh and
to keep up the immunity within the
population because it will be waning
over time so it's always important to
stay up to date with your boosters
and especially if there's a resurgent of
certain cases this summer
so yes
that is the quick answer but yes
we are following very closely uh what is
happening elsewhere and it is possible
it is possible there could be a
resurgence with the a4 and the a5 thank
you
the fda in the states have
uh approved fighter moderna for children
from one
so
what's happening with health canada
right now will there be an approval from
health canada over very quickly maybe
over the next few days
well thank you for that question i
cannot uh
involved with their analysis to look at
the scientific data that the company has
provided for their approval
so we're waiting for this approval it
may be coming over the next few weeks i
can't give you an exact date
but that is the situation right now in
canada and we know that in the united
states
what is happening right now
has uh done that
moderna has
made an application for the children
under five years how to pronounce your
last name
jamie oh hi i'm sorry i did not hear you
guys say anything i'm here can you hear
me
yes
oh hello okay dr new i'm just going to
ask you to um repeat that answer in
english about the coping 19 vaccine
authorization for kids under the age of
five and where we are with those um
submissions here in canada given what
happened in the u.s and the
authorization with the fda today
yes thank you very much uh very simply
at the present time the uh the
submission that's in play that has been
uh submitted to health canada is from
modernity for for that you say the
vaccine for children under five
obviously our our colleagues the
regulator at health canada they're still
in the process of reviewing the evidence
and uh certainly we can anticipate a
decision you know in the coming i would
say weeks or so i can give you a precise
date obviously they need to do their due
diligence and uh maybe further to that
point that the only uh submission that
that's been officially uh put forward to
health canada is for modern at this
point in time
thank you and then my follow-up question
um is for dr tam on on monkey back or
both of you whoever would like to answer
i guess
um
there was a small scale study that found
the current patients who are suffering
from this
strain of monkey pox whatever that may
be
there was the virus found present in
their semen um given that you know we've
been talking about how this isn't an sti
and the who is looking further into
these reports
what is pihac kind of doing to stay on
top of that and does that change the way
we put forth public health
recommendations i guess
yes so um
i think yes we're um very much
aware of that finding
and as far as i know um there's still
looking at whether uh the virus
they get viral growth as of uh those
samples
and so far they
may be just
pcr or
um
to sequencing detection so that's a very
important uh point
uh for the study uh going on
but uh viruses have all sorts of ways of
surprising us and we are learning about
something new about them every day so
i think
it is possible that we will find that
there can be live
virus and semen
right now the
recommendations stand in terms of
you know how the virus is transmitted
including
contact with bodily fluids
these closed contacts and contacts with
skin lesions
and then contaminated objects and so i
think these intimate uh close contacts
including sexual contacts uh are very
much part of our recommendations at the
moment
it's doctor new um uh it's also
reflected in terms of obviously the
guidance we're putting forward for what
we call you know case and contact
management and
obviously as the science evolves we'll
adjust our guidance as as appropriate
and necessary but
at present time we are recommending that
individuals obviously were confirmed of
monkey pox to not to donate bodily
fluids and that includes sperm
laurence martin canada
radio canada
um
in certain regions i was wondering
if you could tell us where exactly and
which regions are you seeing the
resurgence and would you recommend
that a fourth uh
a dose of vaccination the booster be
available to all of the population in
ontario for example the fourth
dose is
it's difficult for us to
our surveillance of waste water maybe
we've seen an increase in certain
atlantic provinces
and also
but it changes from one week to another
so this is something
that we can't declare that something has
become problematic we really had to
follow the trends
the provincial and territorial
authorities will be
making it known
we
so the reality of what is happening
within the territories in the north
compared to atlantic provinces for
example or in bc
it's going to be different
so
it's very important and we thought we
individually
continue to say it's important to have
good individual practices and to stay
updated
up to date with your
vaccination both but dr tam and myself
said have said that even if it's not
required it's a good idea
to wear a mask if you're in a situation
inside if there are a lot of people
you know where you have
a lot of people who are not
are not part of your household so that
is something yes that is important
with the vaccination well
uh
it's complex because each province and
territory have their own policies
in
to go ahead and take advantage of that
what we're seeing in each province and
territory
everyone is
eligible for a third dose so that is
important
to go ahead after your first series of
vaccinations to have at least one
booster if you can get a fourth dose
fourth booster well that's good i think
for more vulnerable populations for
example
for people who are 80 years and older
but i think the principle is really to
stay up to date with your vaccinations
but i think there are probably five
million
canadians who have
done their
their first series so it's important to
finish
your
initial vaccination and then to do the
booster when you're when it's available
to you for the third booster
the federal government announces that
they were suspending even
vaccine mandates
uh travelers also for the public service
so do you think that was too soon does
it work
there is was whether there was a mandate
or not i think that before
public service workers here i don't
think it's it's it's because of the
managers but i think that uh public
future service servants really have done
well
with uh getting the information
and even before it became a mandate i
think that to many of these
and myself as a public servant
i looked at the information and i have
been vaccinated
on my vaccination and when it's whether
or
more than 90
i think it's 95 or maybe 98
of
public servants
i said they have at least two doses of
the vaccine and so i think that that
for me is really the most important fact
and not whether there is a mandate or
not but the fact that
the vast majority of
public
information not only to public servants
but uh and within the federal government
for all canadian unions
it's important to encourage
them to be vaccinated and to give them
the right information
can you hear me yes hello
dr new i wanted to come back on what you
said earlier
you were saying that we're going to have
a resurgent
of uh cases over the summer but not
necessarily another wave
really it depends how you uh
how you define a wave we've had several
but what we've seen
over uh with our collective experience
in canada over the last two years
if there is a resurgence if there's a
great uh a large resurgence that
could be
another wave it would happen more
in the winter months and whereas in the
summer
what we have seen
from experience so that there tends to
be
uh less uh activity
so if we continue this summer with that
tendency we've seen
less of activity of the virus here in
canada but also
we are now seeing
an increase
in the percentage of the the va4 and the
a5 variants and so this is something
that we need to keep a close eye on
because the va4 and va5 variants if we
look at what's happening in europe
with that what we're seeing in europe
they've seen an increase
of the cases in ba four and a five so we
have to
follow this is something that we could
see here in canada thank you very much
and i want to know as an expert in
public health and do you think that it
would be
a good idea in the short term
to uh
to stop
this is the decision made by the
ministers that for myself as a
specialist in health and public health
we can see that mask
is a protective measure an individual
measures and this is something
that
we
can
each decide to do and science has shown
that wearing a mask is gives you a good
level of protection and especially with
you have a vaccination that can protect
you from the variance and we've also
said
you are in a situation
where you have a lot of people
and
where you have where you have a lot of
people that are not part of your
household it is a very good idea to wear
a mask so i think
that whether or not you if you're taking
a plane whether
i think it's important to wear a mask
if you did get covered it would help to
not transmit it to others
yeah um
health canada announced just uh before
you guys came on here for your news
conference that the covet alert app is
being decommissioned there was very low
uptake on it i mean 6.9 million people
downloaded the app however only 57 000
users ended up entering their positive
tests i'm just wondering what your
thoughts are on the decommissioning of
the app and what went wrong with it why
didn't it work to its intended effect
yes i'm not
intimately involved in the app but i
think with
the
we're now you know a number of years
into the pandemic with the activities
epidemic activities uh calming down at
this point and as you say the app not
being utilized to a huge extent i think
the decision was made i believe there is
an actual advisory committee that
oversees the um
the app itself
and so i think it is important
in
such a massive
you know public health
challenge
that innovations take place
not all innovations might work in
different populations but i think it is
good that
there was a good goal at trying to
utilize another tool
in the current era of apps
to try and protect the population
the app does require people um you know
that there's work on both ends of the
local provincial health departments and
to to get to to hand out a key i believe
at least like an electronic key when
someone has a positive test and
and so there's there's a number of steps
that needs to take place um so
i am not sure what you know the the
major challenges when each bit does
depend on a lot of people working
together uh in addition to i think over
six million canadians who downloaded it
so i'm sure there'll be lessons learned
because it would be nice to be able to
utilize some of these newer technologies
as part of our
ongoing
management of outbreaks and pandemics
but but we are where we are today and um
i think um i can't speak to the specific
decisions but um
but but i think people do have to have a
go at innovation
and uh just as a follow-up i know you
were asked about this in in french but
uh just wondering about the decision by
the government to end the vaccine
mandates for domestic travel as well as
outbound travel um
what do you think do you think the
government is moving at the right time
to eliminate these mandates do you have
concerns about this and uh you know
there is the option to bring these
mandates back again should things get
worse where do you see that threshold of
um when we need to reins
reinstate uh vaccine mandates for you
know travel just around canada in a
plane or a train
so i think as i said we're in this
transition period uh we
think that um canada did quite well with
our vaccine coverage but many more
people do need to get their boosters to
get up to date so that is really
important as to whether mandates are the
tools to get people there that can that
is something that uh policymakers will
have to decide on
just because someone doesn't require it
doesn't mean you shouldn't get up to
date so it's still important we just
talked about the fact that disease uh
virus activity could go up and down
uh the virus hasn't left the stage uh it
need it it continues to circulate it
will go up and down and
possibly in the summer but certainly we
we're anticipating in the rise in in
later in the year when respiratory
losses usually increase
i think if uh we'll see what i think
there'll be a significant campaign to
get more people vaccinated as we head
into the
end of the summer into the fourth season
uh so we'll see what happens with that
and what happens to the virus activity
one of the key um
you know indicators of course the
vaccine uptake itself
but the disease activity and the impact
on the health system and whether it's
coping
but i have a tremendous
uh amount of respect for canadians
they've been doing incredible job
i think they will know uh that they they
they're following public health advice
overall
um it is difficult when mandates are
removed or requirements are removed to
remember to
continue to protect yourself because
i think in people sort of
i guess is how your brain works and when
someone removes a requirement you think
oh we don't need it anymore which means
we don't need to get vaccinated we don't
need to wear mass no
i think governments are leaving this to
individuals who have
honed some good habits i hope to carry
on
not just protect themselves but protect
each other you don't know who is sitting
next to you on a plane
so so really be mindful that
you could really help protect each other
and i think they will see how this goes
um but before i i finish my answer i
just want to really actually thank all
the public servants this is national
public service week um and i think
there's a lot of people that
i
i think deserves a thank you for all the
work that they've been doing
at the federal level the public service
has over 98
vaccine coverage already so we think the
mandates have done the job from that
respect
i still would like to encourage every
public servant to get up to date um
and so
uh
thank you are there any other questions
yeti
are there any other questions